What do sudoku games,
wedding seating plans,
and assigning frequencies to radio stations all have in common.
They are all related
to a well-known math problem,
connected to maps.
A proof of this problem was the very
first that relied heavily on a computer.
This breakthrough had a huge impact on
the fields of mathematics and computer science.
But it also ignited decades of debate
about the nature of mathematical proofs,
the role of computers in the field, and
what it means to be a mathematician.
The long and winding journey
started with a simple question.
Imagine you had a blank map
and you're a cartographer,
and you wanted to color the map.
So one thing that might be important is
that each region have its own color and
that no two regions that share
a border are the same color.
And so the question is, how
many colors will you need?
It sounds like a simple
question. How hard can it be?
History surrounding it
is, without a doubt.
One of my favorite episodes
in the history of math.
One might think that this
problem came from cartographers,
but there's really no evidence that mapmakers
have been trying to minimize the number of colors.
Um, this really came from mathematicians.
In 1852, Augustus de Morgan, a
professor at University College London,
brought up the map coloring problem
in a letter to his friend and the
mathematician, Sir William Rowan Hamilton.
It was De Morgan's former student, Francis Guthrie, who
first posed the question.
Guthrie had discovered that he could
shade in all the counties in the United Kingdom
with only four colors.
He wondered if this was the case for
all maps. Regardless of the shape, size,
and complexity.
The simplicity of the Four Color Theorem,
that only four colors are needed to
color any map,
tantalized mathematicians.
However, early attempts to prove it failed.
27 years later, the first widely accepted proof came
from the British barrister, Alfred Kempe.
His proof tackled the problem by analyzing
how countries connect to each other.
To understand how Kemp and other
mathematicians looked at this problem,
it helps to strip away all
unnecessary information.
We can replace each state
by a vertex, a single point.
And if two regions neighbor each other,
we can draw a line segment
between those two vertices.
That's called an edge.
And so we turn this from a map coloring problem
into a graph coloring problem.
Can we color the graph with four or
fewer colors so that neighboring vertices
are not the same color?
This field of math is
known as graph theory,
and it helps mathematicians study
the relationships between objects.
Converting maps to planar graphs,
graphs that can be drawn in a flat plane
with no edges crossing makes the four
color theorem easier to analyze.
It turns out that two maps of different
sizes and shapes can be represented by
equivalent planar graphs.
All that matters is how the regions
are connected and related to one another.
Focusing on only the connections within
the maps helped Kempe discover key
features that all maps share.
Regardless of how complicated,
all maps have, at least one region
that has 0, 1, 2, 3, 4,
or 5 neighbors.
This is known as an unavoidable set.
Once Kempe had identified
an unavoidable set,
he set out to prove
the Four Color Theorem.
To understand a surprising
step of his method, first,
assume that the theorem is false.
Kemp's proof is elegant and clever.
Suppose we cannot color every
map with four or fewer colors,
then there must be a smallest such map.
If the Four Color Theorem is false,
there must be a graph that
requires at least five colors.
This is known as a
minimal counter example.
Kemp wanted to show that he could color
this graph with four colors.
If he could,
then a minimal counter example must
not exist in the first place.
First,
he found one vertex in that graph that
had five or fewer neighbors and removed it.
Then he colored the graph with only
four colors because the graph is smaller than the minimal counter example.
Next, he put the removed vertex back in.
If its neighbors show
three or fewer colors,
there is a color remaining
to color the vertex.
But if the neighbors have all four
colors, then there is a problem.
Kempe then created a method for recoloring
the graph to free up a color for the
remaining vertex.
This allowed him to
recolor it with four colors again.
This showed that a
minimal counter example,
the smallest possible graph that
needs five colors doesn't exist.
That meant the Four Color
Theorem must be true.
Unfortunately, 11 years later, an
error was discovered.
Mathematician Percy Haewood found that Kempe's
recoloring technique worked
when the removed vertex had four or fewer neighbors,
but not when it had five.
When you read Haewood's writing,
you could tell he feels bad for
having discovered this flaw.
So the theorem was a conjecture once
again.
For the next half century, mathematicians continued trying
to prove the four color theorem.
They soon realized that any solution
would require a two-pronged approach.
First, they needed to expand
Kemp's unavoidable set.
This is a collection of configurations
that if you have any graph,
then one of these configurations
must appear in your graph.
The more they looked, the bigger and
more complicated these sets became.
The second task was to prove that
these configurations were reducible,
meaning that if a graph contained
one of these configurations,
then it could be colored
with four or fewer colors.
And proving that these configurations
were reducible also was
harder and harder.
Fortunately, by the end of
the 1960s and early seventies,
computers were becoming
faster and more powerful,
opening the door to new possibilities.
Mathematicians realized
that some of this work,
which was very tedious and
time consuming to do by hand,
might be able to be accomplished
by the use of these new computers.
At this point,
there were several teams trying to solve
the Four Color Problem using computers
At the University of Illinois. Wolfgang
Haken, a well-known topologist,
teamed up with Kenneth Appel,
a mathematics professor,
and one of the only people who knew how
to use the university's new high-powered computers.
In 1976, after about six months of work and more
than a thousand hours of computer
time, they proved the Four Color Theorem.
Haken and Appel found an
unavoidable set consisting of
1,936 reducible configurations.
Every map has to have at least
one of these configurations,
and any map that does can be
colored with four or fewer colors.
Far too many for any human or
even team of humans to check by hand.
At the time, computers were primarily used to perform
mathematical calculations
and not for what was considered the human endeavor
of solving proofs in theoretical mathematics.
As the first major computer assisted proof,
the Four Color Theorem raised questions
about what actually counts as a proof.
Some researchers even questioned the
legitimacy of Appel and Hakens' method.
But if we put ourselves back in the
mindset of 1970s mathematicians,
this idea that one of the most
famous unsolved problems in history
was solved by over a thousand
hours of computer time,
that seems sort of anticlimactic
or not playing by the rules,
these unstated rules
that mathematicians have.
Some people thought that if a human
couldn't read it from end to end,
then it wasn't a legitimate proof.
But as time progressed, the use of computers and theoretical mathematics
became more accepted.
As a younger generation got older,
this newfangled technology just became
the way that we did math.
And uh, today we're much more comfortable
with it than we were at that time.
Today, mathematicians often use computers
to check proofs of theorems or even to
generate proofs themselves.
This fruitful and continuing marriage
of mathematics and computers all started
with a seemingly simple
question of how to color maps.
Through the study of this problem
mathematics was created and
advanced in so many ways.
This was one of the major drivers of
the study of graph theory
or network theory.
The ideas behind these
theories are now ubiquitous.
We use graphs and networks to describe
the way disease spreads and the way
computer networks are connected.
While the four color theorem might
seem like a mathematical curiosity,
it really did push the boundaries
of mathematics forward.